in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
another genius brain podcast I hope you
guys are coronavirus free out there we
got a very special guest today you know
these guys actually started their own
podcast called big med we got Alex over
here yeah so today is actually just an
intervention you [ __ ] mango eating
[ __ ] a minute though [ __ ] I actually
wanted to ask everybody who listens to
this podcast
who the [ __ ] eats mangoes with the
[ __ ] skin on zero people zero people
I'm sure all my salary's out there know
what it is so TIFF TIFF sperits their
salvation 200% mm-hmm I asked the mom I
said mom mama Garcia why are you talking
like that I asked her I said hey people
eat mango skins with with uh do I do
people you mangoes to the skin on his El
Salvador and she looked at me she goes
mmm not really she was like she had a
think about it she said no and then
later she goes yeah they actually do see
that's Holland the fact that she was
like actually that's that's a big song
about the listen to the full set she was
like this she goes I if they don't have
any more oh nice to use machete to cut
the man right so my daddy's from
Salvador to our table ever since we were
kids he used to give us the mango it
might have been laziness who knows
all I know is that when I eat that [ __ ]
on my right now you also told me the ax
dad used to beat you as if you do your
spaghetti so that's true that your dad
do what the [ __ ] he was doing I'm pretty
sure you guys said I want mangoes and he
was like [ __ ] you kids eat the skin and
then you're like actually kind of good
only reason why cuz he used to eat it
too but I should spawn me take that
first bite and then you put that Thai he
and all over that every single bike so
it's the time that that does most of the
heavy lifting because Tajin on fruits is
a straight-up belt on the skin though
you got to take the first bite before
the tacking sticks so I said you gotta
take the first bite and then then that
mango shone and you dip it
hey but tell him hey tell us so this is
what it is
haha let's start with this story though
so he's been he's been pressing this
whole mango skin thing on me for the
longest time dumbest thing it's the
funniest thing how when you sometimes by
I don't know dehydrated mangoes do you
ever see the [ __ ] skin on absolutely
not so this guy's because they can't
dehydrate with the skin on
yeah they get na so he's been pressing
this whole [ __ ] mango thing so he
finally brings a juicy ass [ __ ] mango
he's a very juicy mango now prior to
this though we had a conversation and he
was like watch look that [ __ ] up and see
what happens I've never seen that man
show us facts right but he covers half
the facts with his thumb read from here
down are edible and there's possibly
vitamins in the skin he received done he
takes the phone away it goes but there's
a lot of pesticides in the skin and it's
advised that you don't eat it because
it's a bitter cuz if you don't clean it
right though so before he would tell us
that he would eat the mangoes in the
skin I'd be like yeah I bet like I bet
it's like doesn't taste that bad but he
brought one for us David took a buy it
win that bet yeah wasn't that bad but
after I took a bite of mine I doubled
down on my stance and I changed
completely I said what is it was so good
just didn't want to agree with everybody
no no and it wasn't that good but no one
else was like everybody was like
lukewarm everybody was like I will say
this so that was probably the best pic
mangal anybody has never had one but it
was so unnecessary you want everybody
said they're like oh this will be better
without the skin that's what everybody
said a hundred percent I didn't hear
that I'm telling you it's all I told
them because remember our homie
ilex picked out a yellow mango I told
him like those ones aren't the best you
should like dried us [ __ ] like it wasn't
a problem I'm like yeah that's not know
I should juices came out though that
[ __ ] was juiciest [ __ ] yeah but is that
crunch don't Wayne you know if you eat
mangos with the skin on comment I bet
every let us know everyone's gonna come
out of the Woodworks everybody is gonna
comment they're just gonna [ __ ] leave
a comment on your page and try to get
you banned from Instagram but a mango
sponsor me I guess I'll eat them huh
there's no company called mega general
eat a Kiwi out of bananas crazy crazy
says you can eq with the skin i've never
tried it but i'm i want to try it people
actually people say that it's like
putting a nut sack in your mouth bro
that's just various but not that I would
know though people do eat it boss then
they had me try a shrimp it's the same
thing that I think about with shrimp
y'all eat a whole [ __ ] shrimp I've
never [ __ ] done that before and it
took me 13 minutes to eat the [ __ ]
shrimp let's talk about the shrimp
situation too but I've known Alice maybe
a year at most right
this [ __ ] is the weirdest guy
I've ever met
craziest palette dude this fool first of
all most people when they try new foods
they kind of second-guess their options
right they go maybe I'll eat that and
like it looks a little weird we say hey
have you tried this girl's not he's just
asked about the process he shoves it and
he chews at it like a [ __ ] the
shabu for the first time that was so
bombed yeah first time you did it though
because this dude's you cook his noodles
so much that she look like Elmer's he's
so stubborn I was like you cook you do
like this we'll say he goes that's how I
like it when you make the the noodle
like the block noodle yeah put it says
three minutes I'll put it in for like
five minutes so they're all like super
squishy Wow why do you do it for five
minutes because it's hotter and it boils
the the noodle food this fool has never
had this much Asian food in this light
never a swerve on me for the second time
to the second time the first one I
didn't really get to choose what it was
though this time I got to choose it was
fire
hey the bread that they used to is kind
of like bolillo bread Tiffani would know
it she would know what it is because
it's I told him was like yeah she came
upon us yeah I know nothing about Salvi
flour
I don't know only thing I've ever had
was like pupusas that's bomb - I mean
you can't go wrong with that but pine
cone Pavo is fire dude we got to take
him to a spa
he loves it well you just go over the
tip sauce whenever they make it for cuz
to eat it she doesn't like that stuff I
don't know tip you working at a hospital
she got coronavirus she ain't no but
really I've never had this much Asian
food and like he gave me duck for the
first time oh what'd you think about the
duck slapped best I'm sorry that's just
slap dude that was good that little
orange sauce or whatever you put on it
yeah and then he added this bun that had
meat in it to my Apple bun the barbecue
pork and the butter inside come on you
literally eat anything that's put in
front of your face that I will and I
really will the one thing I ate I went
to like some Chinese buffet in Arizona
when I lived there a lot of sounds
already discussed I don't know what it
was it was something they said like deep
oceans now right oh yeah yeah yeah oh
she smells the fire I like that okay so
with garlic and butter television so it
was in the shell though and I pulled it
out right and this one was kind of thick
and I swear on my life so um they're
coming in I'm asking my girl so how do
you eat this right like I asked the
ladies and like I'll just pull it and
eat it
am i okay and then she calls a person
over right and she's like she says
something he's she's like oh yeah I just
pull that out and eat it I was like okay
if you didn't told me that all right so
I put in my mouth and I'm trying to chew
on it and nothing's happening right I'm
like okay that [ __ ] popped off in my
mouth I don't think that's well said
that's not it popped in my mouth I just
killed a bunch of baby snail it popped
about Rio and I swear so I had a drink I
put I drank my coke
I started swishing around my mouth
leaned over my table open my mouth it
just started dripping slop my mouth so
I'd I start grabbing napkins and stuff
like that and they were just sitting
there smiling I'm like I think they did
this [ __ ] to me on purpose
way way way it came out of your mouth
yeah cuz I opened my mouth so it was
like all sticky and [ __ ] in my mouth so
I drink coke to try to like you know
like what you do with mouthwash ocean
snail is not supposed to be less yeah
they're supposed to be like a clam so
you probably ate a raw snail dude that
is the most disgusting
I'm telling you after I swear I was with
the coke like and I open I stop you know
it slowly started dripping out I was
tripping out I'm like yo I kid you not
you in a raw [ __ ] georgians don't eat
that at a buffet dude dog you ate a raw
osius no you know what happened
you ate a raw guess why I'm [ __ ] you
know what's a call I'm immune to Corona
dog
you're the source I'm sorry dog if we
put bat superfriends green bugs before
yeah go ahead like crickets and [ __ ]
like that I really wanted to try like
two scorpions and stuff when I was a
little kid like I tried you know have
you guys ever seen those little red and
black bugs ladybugs
they look like long and flat like they
don't have wings trying to think of what
beats no it's weird but crazy like
design on it some reason when I was a
kid at school like it was like the cool
thing I was like in second grade I would
eat them and people would trip out
eating bugs how hard was your life
those kids were eating bugs and your
dad's like amen take care of you this
kind of explains everything about Alex
this makes sense Michael [ __ ] were you
eating bugs off the floor cuz is there
anything you wouldn't eat like what so
it's like you're like oh I won't even
touch that besides [ __ ] deep sea
snail from Ares as long as I don't know
what it is like you know we're going to
the Asian spots you guys tell me this
food like the names like number one I
can't pronounce him and I don't know
what they are right so you guys tell me
that's fine I'll eat it but if you were
to tell me like he told me today I told
him this today
he told me there's like liver paste or
some pate yeah yeah if see if you just
say pate am i cool eat it
that's so weird that you talk about
liver like that but as a child you've
all the flooring and you're like that's
just slap and then you grab they don't
taste like anything you do a quick oh
yeah but why would you even think about
eating no why honey because like I said
everybody thought it was cool and
everybody will watch me do it so I was
just like oh [ __ ] ah damn but out of my
tongue so let me go let me just write
them so I got to collect this [ __ ]
you're on the plane you chillin right
and the buggies on the floor chillin
though [ __ ] all the playground chillin
this [ __ ] centipede piles on the
floor and they were like ah ha become a
cool of you
and you're like bet and then you said oh
and they're like best I do like I'm
gonna be doing this for six years - yeah
so the bugs and my it's weird cuz like
for some reason when I would do [ __ ]
like that another thing I used to crush
cans on my head oh you would do all
these tonight can I just say this right
now we just sparred today and I threw a
light hook at his head my knuckles hurt
a head is the thickest thing I've ever
placed my knuckles on it doesn't even
matter if you get into a pro fight
you're gonna knock people out just by
breaking their hands on your head it was
good big head gang but for real but when
I started doing this sort of it wasn't
hot this was high school right and you
know I don't know when you guys were in
high school like before after at lunch
do you always had the same table that
she went to right so he always had the
same table and one day they we had those
big Arizona iced tea cans yeah and like
I just grabbed it this [ __ ] hold on a
second we got a pause real quick
an Arizona iced tea it's like the psyche
and ruler there's a whole ruler imma
blow your mind already there's a trick
to it though so your other boy that the
cam was full with liquid you can get a
shower because it was no so you have to
hold it like this
uh-huh and you kind of like right you
have to time it perfectly that's why my
timing impeccable striking impeccable
right
right before it hits you have to squeeze
your fingers oh this is the most useless
knowledge that tell you why it's not
doing anybody any high school loser this
there you go new trick to make you some
money finesse all these kids right right
before it hits you squeeze and it
smashes down so easy right so I did it
once and arrows are all with the hill so
I was like you know a put some money on
the table I'll start crushing cans right
so hold on a sec way what the [ __ ] is
wrong that one weird kid that would do
anything for a dollar
that motherfucker's here's the thing
right my old brother loved him dumbest
[ __ ] though because my parents when he
was in high school he was like oh yeah
cuz he is some small skinny kid right oh
I only need like we only need 20 bucks a
week for lunch right and this is before
we had jobs that [ __ ] bought you a
[ __ ] french fry in a small soda
that's all I could get you Monday Friday
right so like we're either still in
month are stealing food from the
cafeteria or I asking homies to buy a
[ __ ] then I started smashing cans upon
my head you know say good I said how the
taco line okay text your friends this is
a picture
[ __ ] bell rings right class is over
this book goes out I see this will at
the specific lunch table going last one
at the tag Alice Costa need some lunch
you want to see some ass it only went on
for like literally like two three weeks
but the word only doesn't come before
two three weeks
yeah that's a long-ass time for so
people are entertained by your [ __ ]
can smashing for your high school you
know along two or three weeks --is for
Isis venture after that [ __ ] I started
working at Burger King
okay but no yeah so all I would do is
buy a whatever you guys have just thrown
on the table each day I would only do
one can at lunch so this is only at
lunch right I wasn't just like between
class I hey come through come in and
smash my [ __ ] right before class right
and I probably make like 4 or 5 dollars
every single every single day for like
three weeks this makes so much sense
though kind of about you right here and
it sometimes don't know looky right I
would do it into a [ __ ] I'm good and
going back to my shit's all bruised
circle you know what the funny thing is
because raps of [ __ ] you're hilarious
about your life are the most hilarious
thing ever you know I was broke as [ __ ]
bring up cans over the forehead
pretty poor around some lippy but we've
ever had a [ __ ] break hands over a
cash me on the corner crushed can not
get the study right no you try slaying
some drugs for some money-mad good it's
going good for me Yasha hop in yeah
start a whole pyramid scheme by you sign
up three people to smash cans you got it
you don't have to do it no more you
start talking like James Toney real
quick dude I stutter a lot - that could
be it but I do think because one time
when we were little kids we had like you
know how like you have like cabinets
like this we had it on a wall and me and
my brother were wrestling and we had one
of those old ass TVs all right with this
the back sticking out of in shape you
eat that too with the skin kind of days
weird nah no we were wrestling we're
wrestling and all of a sudden I was like
I was like fading in from a white right
like it was all the Sun everything was
white and it was slowly fading in that
TV fell and smashed all the sudden like
we were playing and all the sudden I'm
like what the [ __ ] is it was like by
coming from white to color and my
brothers I call you good
like the [ __ ] thing he said from what
not dude dude I got so many like we had
we had this big-ass staircase on that
house right we had a dog named Neko
right I shout out EIRP Neko men above
nuga and what's it called he so he used
to like hate us as kids right yes so we
still like [ __ ] with him on purpose and
I was standing at the top of the stairs
right yeah and he was sitting there
looking at me and I was doing like he
used to hate when he used to go like at
him he didn't matter if you in his face
or far away right and then all sudden he
started going so you knew he was getting
mad this bull starts running at me and
jumps to bite me and I was already on
the rail and I kind of jumped but I
jumped too much and I fell off the
complete top flew and landing on our
computer desk bounced off landed on my
stomach on the floor and just got up and
started running
I I wasn't hurt at all that's [ __ ]
insane dude how the [ __ ] are you alive
man
yo after you died they got to do a study
on that skull [ __ ] for a bullet proof
yes I think I've only ever met one
person that I know our homie Gilbert
that's the same size head as me
that full is mission of pan face goop
it's our head it's like the same like I
guess thickness but our head looks so
different you guys don't even need a
spar with your hands just headbutt the
[ __ ] out of people do but the thing
matches your body cuz you like your bug
you Gilbert nd when when that fool is uh
when he was doing keto and he lost a
bunch of weight he looked like a
lollipop for losing seeing pictures I'm
like damn look at that dome dude yeah I
got like that little hotdog pack right
here till my neck
I do my neck when I got big so I didn't
get like like what was your biggest ice
I was 270 okay so I got 250 which is
different right because I've been 250
again like five seven five seven but the
first time I got 250 wasn't like good
like it was like a lot of fat my neck
was 20 inches right [ __ ] so like this
was so big and I was telling him like
there used to be times where I'd be like
laying on my on my pillow and then all
sudden go like I started choking myself
no choking on your own fat dude I never
been that fat though it was a mixture of
crazy I was a mixture of like I have a
big neck right from lifting it's a lot
of tensing up in your neck and it builds
the muscles but then it was getting ya
know just like oh yeah but yeah
[Applause]
everybody that supported my hustle the
Smashing cans long when we first met
Alex know when I first but he'd this one
wouldn't say anything he was so [ __ ]
mad quiet
first time I met that I was very
skeptical of him cuz you look at it
quiet this guy's deal I could have
figured this dude out cuz he literally
wouldn't like he wouldn't disclose too
much information about himself until now
where he's telling us his [ __ ] origin
story mm-hmm and it's literally the
craziest thing I've ever saw when I met
Nick I fight Academy like I met
obviously all the coaches everybody's
cool there but I was I ain't I could see
like nick is cooler and I was still knew
her - not cooler but I mean like I could
vibe with him right apologies every now
and then you guys know I grew up in
Sacramento I'm trying not to use that
word it's just because you know I'm from
Southside Phoenix that's when I grew up
to LA I say though it's like that's the
first time I've ever slipped up on a
podcast I'm not guys like I'm saying
I've done my best not to say it it's
just when I go back to second you what
happens those because I was just on the
phone with my buddy from Sacramento
right the obviously a black guy but
sometimes people just get weirded out
when I go back home it like y'all say
that anymore I'm like and people don't
understand it's like yeah that's all I
hung out with right was black people and
like even in rap music when we were
rapping I would say it all the time -
yeah it was no issue we'd go to parties
freestyle in front of a bunch of people
was no issue but you know I've gotten
used to not saying it but like when we
hang out and like you know because I
feel like when like I saw you know when
I when when this whole topic was a big
issue specifically on Facebook everybody
on the moms we're talking about it right
there like you know if you say that word
you're a piece of [ __ ] if you're not
black right but even within the black
community people don't like black people
using it that's why my thing is like
look if black Americans as a culture
can't figure it out then we should just
have them say it at all right
that's their thing so when uh I started
getting irritated because I knew
specific people that grew up saying that
word their whole [ __ ] life and
they're on Facebook [ __ ] on other in
abouts I can't believe you would use
that word I'm like just we're using the
two years ago how the [ __ ] did you [ __ ]
on people like you should be like okay I
understand now but they're trying to act
as if they've never used it before yeah
because in Sacramento a lot of people
use that word it was it was just like I
was I remember the first time somebody
taught me how to use it when I was a
little kid it was so my parents owned
obviously everybody knows that they
owned a black beauty supply store so
every Thursday Friday and Saturday there
used to be a block party right mm-hmm it
was kind of like that so Thursday Friday
Saturday night block party would come
out I [ __ ] you not like roughly around
5:00 p.m.
people would put up cardboard a shed
next to my parents a store and they
would just start shooting dice si
outside of my favorite store and our
story to this joint called Lord Tony's
artistic fingers and so they heated
nails and weaves and all of the [ __ ] so
he was like a nail shop and lo and
behold the guy went to jail he had
shutters shipped down but there was a
block party every weekend and I used to
be that young little asian kid that was
outside and all like the the black dudes
the oh geez with what I would kick it
with their banshees you have played dice
and that's when Danny became a dice
champion exactly will come out my pimp
suit but they would encourage me to say
that [ __ ] all the time so like for me it
would just became like one of those
things where I felt like I was a part of
an exclusive group and that's David's
organist Orion that's his orchestra
that's my normal origin story they'll be
shooting dices [ __ ] and there was this
dude named Mose that had a food truck
out there and he would even tell me to
say that [ __ ] right so he would call me
every time order the same [ __ ] I would
get the Philly cheesesteak because my
parents liked that [ __ ] and I used to
get these things shoutouts to Jim boys
time response to me Jim Boyce is like
just now North Cal like [ __ ] and
Avenue 26
oh yeah Avenue 26 ah I used to get those
little fried tacos I used to order it
every time and every time I walked up he
called me a little n-word
I said oh I feel great you're like oh
this guy
it is weird like the same thing right
growing up with kids like I remember
specifically I had a best friend in
fifth grade who literally wanted me to
say it because he had like it was cool
right we were best friends
he's a you can say it you can call me it
like I'm it probably sounds weird but he
wanted me to say right so like I already
had a young yeah but then just growing
up where we grew up right I grew up
around a lot of Hispanics and black
people a lot of bloods and that type of
stuff and it was just normal and then
growing up a lot of my friends Hispanics
a lot of Hispanics say it that's not
like not known right actually out here -
yeah and yeah so it was kind of normal
but I would say we're pretty good at
when we're in professional settings
obviously we're not just dropping it
like all the time right like I know
there's a switch I know when it's okay
to be said and not to be people of our
generation are slowly dying out with
that well obviously not in the hood
areas I think they're gonna be there I
think it's it's like it was because it
was such an integral thing and it wasn't
a big issue when we were growing up we
just have to make that shift now yeah
that's the hard part is the shift and
what I always tell people is like you
know sometimes when people slip up like
even my friends too like they still say
it but they're black so you know that is
ways so but that you know there's like a
grace period they're just like okay the
[ __ ] that's happening it's gonna take a
while for people to kind of get that out
of their system because that's what they
grew up with and it was using a positive
term but yeah now it's just to be
mindful of just like okay everybody yeah
everybody yeah and that was a thing to
like when I moved out here right I knew
my mom and like my aunt uncle so like
obviously when I was meeting new people
I wasn't just saying it all the time
that word up if you did though you
should skip that just comes down here
it's okay now yeah but yeah you probably
you probably get away with them more if
you just said in that accent Oh your
body
Oh for sure if I if I had a thick
Chinese accent funny love if you do that
that's where or they'd murder you either
were it's just like I don't know MIT you
know when I had this I did a college
show and it is so funny because
sometimes you don't realize that the
reach of the stuff that you do like on
this platform because I've been on this
platform now for ten plus years yeah so
some of these kids who have seen me they
see me since they were 11 or 12 years
old which I don't even know why they
were watching my [ __ ] that you have an
agent you know they loved it they they
define their personalities off of the
stuff that I've said that's also
internet kids too you know yeah and I
would never think that that was the
ripple effect that I would have funniest
[ __ ] [ __ ] I go to this college show
this Chinese kid comes up to me right my
man's right here he came up to me here
as a hey David I gotta tell you
something man like I came here when I
was 12 years old I learned how to curse
from your [ __ ] dough I'm like a man
you need to tone it a little bit you
ain't gotta curse that much man but he's
like he said he'd learned how to speak
English and curse for me damn worst
person to learn how to speak English
from there nah but you're very very
eloquent the worst thing is hearing
someone cuts and you can like physically
tell that they don't want to but they're
trying to do it
I had a homie like that too and he would
be like yeah what the [ __ ] just commit
bro
you don't have to cuss cuz he hang out
with this that [ __ ] here's the [ __ ]
funny thing right as a young kid I would
drop I would drop the n-bomb all the
time right but I would never curse and
it's cuz I grew up at a church and so
when I used to say the f-word mm-hmm
f-word oh yeah I used to like it used to
make me feel like I was gonna go to hell
tomorrow because my dad's a pastor yeah
so that was a weird thing like I
remember as a kid cursing and feeling
like a piece of [ __ ] like I would I
would say the words like I was a [ __ ] or
[ __ ] and that I think might you this is
like when I was like 13 years old but I
remember when I was cursing I used to
feel sick inside my stomach because my
because I grew up in a church household
that was a really wholesome kid that was
stabbing people in the face you know
Bible story for a good reason though
they deserved it they're messing with
you that fools even mangle in front of
me with the skin on I straight up yeah I
used to feel really sick in my stomach
cursing I remember I used to when I when
I curse because I was trying to kick it
with people I was that kid because I was
at all these people curves and I'd be
like what sounds so weird yeah I'm sure
this won't surprise you but I've been
cussing since like forever right we me
and my brothers were always good to
where we never did it in front of our
parents like my mom or dad yeah yeah
kindergarten yeah
cussing it just my dad says I'm sorry
like a kindergarten bro yeah sorry five
years old
yeah idea what's the matter with you
dad's favorite words my Papa's favorite
words ah [ __ ] [ __ ] right those two words
right my uncle I for real a lot of
Hispanics have this uncle they say [ __ ]
for everything know that [ __ ] thing
was [ __ ] crazy right like he's one of
those right so my my mom just said like
she would say like [ __ ] and stuff right
and ass and [ __ ] but yeah we were
cussing from everybody I'm definitely
gonna be that uncle that's gonna be
dropping f-bombs but the weird thing is
a lot of my friends they be cursing for
the kids all the time no but their kids
aren't allowed to curse so I don't
understand that like don't do a thing
because that's what happened to us and
then we were unlike we were terrified to
do and we like we wouldn't ever want to
do
in front of my dad even to this day my
dad's like hey stop cussing my [ __ ] that
[ __ ] dog like trying to fight or woof
what stop talking my dad never peel the
mangoes on the floor I'll be the [ __ ]
love you son let me Papa loved him yeah
yeah so if no one knows it's a story my
dad was on the people that we sat at the
table
he gave us food he gave us food weeding
it to choose how much we got he was one
of the ones where we weren't allowed to
just be like oh you know I'm fool I'm
gonna go put this in the sink go in my
room whenever like that we had to get up
from the table walk to the couch show
him our plate or a bowl and then he had
to approve it if he said no yeah go to
prison yeah bro that's not what's a
prison I don't know if he ever did
honestly I don't think he did I know my
uncle did the [ __ ] uncle he went of
course [ __ ] he was sure but yeah I love
all my uncles my dad in the [ __ ] but
it's funny my dad was like that so like
he used to give a spaghetti and like we
never had snacks like in the house
growing up and stuff like that you know
parents lived on a tight budget but when
he would make spaghetti the bowl was
like [ __ ] five pounds of spaghetti
right and your size [ __ ] every time we
make is he making like twice a week
you're like god damn right like so
someone came up off the say you were
sitting with me you wanted to go get a
drink of water I'm trying to scoop my
[ __ ] up in your bowl right like cuz it
was so much oh yeah so much spaghetti
for because we eat throughout like the
day like say if it was like a weekend
right we didn't go to school and have
school lunch yeah like we he would make
us breakfast sometimes or sometimes like
you know we just eat like something
small something like that and then we'd
eat spaghetti for dinner right or he
yeah our ramen he wouldn't make I
remember that was like a big thing in
our house he would make ramen you put a
bunch of ramen put eggs in ten minutes
cook the noodles for farmyard naho but
eggs
yeah so like I remember it was weird cuz
growing up like I started started to
realize like when my dad started making
better money you know as like food
started changing if we started changing
cuz I still remember one day I don't
i've never even told him this that I
remembered it I think I might have told
you this story but there was one night
where he like tried to send this to the
bed right he's like Oh guys go to bed
it's bedtime and it was like earlier
than our normal bedtime and so like I
remember going to bed and I was just
really hungry
and we didn't eat dinner yet right so
I'm like I got I go out into the living
room my dad's like what's up I'm like
I'm just I'm hungry I'm really hungry is
that I go back in your room right so
then like 20 minutes past he's like all
right guys come out here and eat right
and it was just look like corn tortillas
with some like mayonnaise and a hotdog
on it and then like the next day he went
in like it was I think it was like a
Friday went and got a bunch of food so
now that I'm older I realize like oh he
probably didn't have any money to go get
food he was trying to send us to bed and
then just made up some [ __ ] right it's
like corn tortilla mayonnaise and a hot
dog okay first of all that was the
biggest struggle meal I've ever heard in
my life you said my dad had a tortilla
mayonnaise and hot dogs did give you the
hot dog man yeah but that's why I love
my parents because they tried to never I
never knew we were like broke growing up
right I never knew I was broke growing
up yeah it was like weird cuz I would
always get like hand-me-down like
clothes or something like that right but
like my dad we didn't know at the time
but he would take a selector outlets
right to get shoes like once for right
before school started you got we got a
pair of shoes and like at the mills mall
it was like an outlet mall right so
cheap clothes but that was the time we
got closed but as we started getting
older my dad you know both of my parents
my mom started getting higher up
positions and stuff like that
we were like oh let's go eat out that
filtered water down yeah let's go eat
out let's go do this as go do that so it
was cool now that I'm older and I can
see and like I know about money
and how tight money can get and stuff
it's kind of cool to see like all my
parents still like kept us all together
ya know they were divorced right they
were divorced from when I was a kid we
got to switch houses every week but both
of them made it so with like we never
knew that that's the interesting - I
feel like because I didn't know that I
was poor and I've said this before until
I went to college it's when I started
comparing my life to other people's
lives and they would say like crazy [ __ ]
like man we used to go on vacation I was
like vacation time off you spend money
to go to a different country I'm like
with what you're like for why though
yeah why they're like to have fun
fine what you mean fun and cut like they
would say some crazy [ __ ] like I like I
started comparing my life and especially
like especially kids who did get their
ass beat I would start telling stories
about me getting my ass beat and they
were like they're horrified they were
like yeah they felt they were horrified
or they feel sorry for me I'm like y'all
got stories like that like no my parents
would talk yeah my talk like these crazy
stuff to me that was crazy but to them
my life was so weird like they thought
you know because I got my ass beat we
grew up really poor and that was the
thing - cuz I started realizing my
parents were making money - was the same
thing we would go out to eat dinner a
little more yeah my parents are really
smart about not letting people know how
much we were struggling because they
didn't want any had hand-me-downs or had
meows right so it was hard because I
feel like a lot of Asian people - even
though they're struggling financially
they all take welfare because they think
that's a sign of weakness so it's like
[ __ ] man
take the [ __ ] welfare man leave this
money but I would have never known at
the time either way cuz my parents were
so good at like hiding and guarding us
from that [ __ ] yeah cuz every close that
I had was a hand-me-down or right around
my parents store so there's like the
liquor store we use called poon jabs
apparently it's not the name
because there's Punjabi people I know
what's a Punjabi person real quick a
Punjabi person is well it's Indian
Punjabi right the same they get really
particular about that but I think they
were servants no the male's wear turbans
the Punjab's I believe one of my best
friends growing up was a Punjabi his
Punjabi yeah you call them Punjab any
Punjabi people out there feel free to
write in the comments it correct this
because I would like people to know the
difference and but so this is joint
called Punjab's doing jabs and what we
call them we just call them poon jabs my
whole life I thought it was the name of
store but it is not I only found out a
few years ago when I went back oh yeah
I'm gonna go to Punjab real quick and
get a drink like what and it just says
liquor store I'm like oh my god holy
[ __ ] everybody in the neighborhood I'll
call that Punjab and it got to the point
where the owner said welcome to poon
jabs so it's just that point but it was
I guess it started off as like a
racially derogatory thing yeah but after
a while you know once you become a part
of the neighborhood your neighborhood
staple you know it's just is what it is
like everybody you know yeah like people
used to call my dad and word ccino ccino
so I'm like oh so that's what it's like
so I just like a brown mix in there yeah
but I never knew that I grew up poor and
then we started making a little more
money than foods food is the biggest fan
starts to change I remembered like I
used to get kind of hungry at night and
then one time I dad I think is we had
food and we always ate well because
Korean food is not that expensive to
make specifically Asian food back in the
day because a lot of the throw away food
that American people like now shoutouts
to my white people [ __ ] you guys for
making oxtails so expensive just kidding
I love white people yeah every time we
go I gotta try one oh you like get that
oxtail soon you don't like you don't
like top restaurants up with that I know
what's up what you're not liking tops
bro that's the oxtail soup man that
you're missing out on bro it's [ __ ]
firemen so delicious
yeah but they sell fried rice for the
oxtail used to be great like if you went
to all our everyone
like a white grocer it was like a
throwaway [ __ ] so they would just my mom
would used to get ox tails and we should
get oxtail soup all the time we grew up
drinking to oxtail soup yeah so you know
food was like mad cheap for us it's like
cabbage fermented vegetables and when
that [ __ ] would not hipster you know now
it still hipster for some reason but
even my aunt didn't know that we were
poor cuz I was it was so funny so I was
hanging out with this one this youtuber
like we say all the time like she's
doing her own thing
shoutouts to a [ __ ] I go shut her eyes
we should kick it a lot but my aunt and
I was like telling her like yeah like we
didn't have a lot of money growing up my
mom was like you have you had money and
I was like what are you talking about
she was like laughing she like you guys
had money and I was like what the [ __ ]
if I would know like why people always
want to also like think that they know
about your life exactly you know and so
when I got really entertained in that
conversation and I was like how the [ __ ]
would you guys know like your husband
we're the government [ __ ] job and you
guys were fine you guys were fine the
whole time you guys would go on
vacations while we would sit in our ass
and watch you go on vacation so what the
[ __ ] do you know so I called my mom and
I was like yo how come auntie things
that we grew up money she goes because
she never knew we never told her about
how much we were struggling like she
just never [ __ ] knew sounds like oh
I'll say watch you coming out the side
of my mouth like that to me what the
[ __ ] do you know like you didn't ask her
[ __ ] on your parents though cuz like no
one needs to know your guys is big you
know and that was a thing yet like that
was the biggest thing was food right so
like we never had snacks in her house
like saying here pop-tarts and all that
type of [ __ ] right we never used to have
it so when I was in elementary school I
remember like third fourth fifth grade
is when we started going to a town
called agua cooky right which was kind
of like a richer area we just call all
white Tookie and that's okay all right I
like the people out there were like bad
money so like I remember had a couple
friends especially in fourth grade was
the biggest one when my friend was like
oh you cuz he was used to bring
pop-tarts and this is when I found out
about hot fudge sundae pop-tarts if you
haven't had those the best pop-tarts
just ledge sundae I actually just like
the strawberry one
I like 1/2 that's one of my favorite
ones brown sugar is good too round
certifiers strawberries bomb blueberry
throw it away
Sunday dude rid of it he brought it once
I'm I'll do what's that and he gave me a
bite on my oh [ __ ] I'm like nah he
started Brit he would bring me pop-tarts
every single day do we take it to a
restaurant something's [ __ ] fire this
fool eats like the most basic [ __ ] he
goes nowhere to chef at this blanched
spinach right now that was a thing yeah
no snacks this is a point right I
remember remember this so clearly at my
mom's house in North Phoenix we didn't
have anything to eat and snack on we
used to walk home from school after
school my brother Michael he goes in
there he comes out he starts eating
something I'm like what is it he's like
bacon right I'm like bacon I was like
bacon and I look at I go in the pantry
he was eating the dog treats that look
like bacon oh I was like he was like
taste the same
I'm like dog straight up did you see
that documentary on Netflix I'm gonna
talk about another podcast but it's like
this other this document about that kid
who got beat up and he got on that's
your life dude like were they what they
would just the seat what's it called
with [ __ ] social service your life
social service failure fell your ass
yeah we knit we didn't have snacks no
chips or something like that
you guys didn't have any snacks in your
house to the point when he saw dog food
he was like yes that's alright I think
that's what [ __ ] white people cost
next
I think this what they call bacon yeah
that was funny that's funny that your
dog has snacks but you guys did but you
guys did that snack it was cool like I
said I like the way out now that I'm
older I'm very happy and we didn't get
hit by any hit us I maybe got spanked
one time but Mike I should have got
smacked I know but Mike he just looked
at us and he did this like this hand
just the hand like all screams together
and we were just kind of scared of him
so we never did anything so I'd be mad
when I got grounded when we got grounded
and I see this nowadays even with people
I know that have kids when they ground
their kids I'm like you're not grounding
them right when we got grounded we were
grounded in like I remember fifth grade
was my worst year I told you guys
stories about fifth grade right fifth
grade was my worst year I got grounded
for a month and that was a month and
that was that both houses every Friday
we switched the house that house nothing
how to stay in my room only able to
leave to go bathroom eat and shower both
houses that was us when we got grounded
but I see people even my little sister
gets grounded she's going out with her
friends like two days later I'm like
well she was grounded what the hell's
going on what's grounded bed to them cuz
grout my parents tried to ground me but
that [ __ ] didn't work a lot of jackoff
all day in the room they'll be like
you're grounded I'm like please I beg
you ground me so much [ __ ] in my spank
bank I got an older brother get all the
ready he was he was my older brother
comparatively to me he was the golden
child right so he went to UC San Diego
got really good grades never got into a
single fight his whole life his aim
screen name and his nickname in high
school was goody two-shoes because he
would never ever occur when you meet his
brother you're like oh you guys aren't
related at all yeah he's like he's like
five foot eight how old is he older than
you he's three years old and beers
that's like my oldest brother he's like
super calm and he's very share rooms
when you're growing up
yup so my brother used to share this
room with my grandpa back in the day cuz
we used to live in this duplex cuz we
were broke his folks out to being poor
poverty
shut up so my brother I think I slept I
didn't have a separate room where did I
say I eat this up with my parents from
my slept in the living room
my brother had to share a room with my
grandpa and my brother said that this
will used to sleep with his eyes open
his doors locked eyes ever since and so
I didn't believe that [ __ ] till later on
I was like 8 years old and we were
living with on the weekends with my
grandparents and then I saw that [ __ ]
firsthand
like my grandpa would talk in his sleep
with his eye slightly open grandma would
also sleep with this eyes slightly open
it was scariest [ __ ] man for each
other yeah I've reason why I asked you
because that was the thing where I
shared the room with both brothers yeah
so like I couldn't really be like going
and jacking off going on [ __ ] but my
brother was never grounded so he was out
playing so I just be jacking it yeah and
that [ __ ] was crazy too I don't know
like we had a small last room right I
was just telling my homie this story
right our room was very small we had
everything for the three boys right
everything in there it used to get
really really really hot and I used to
tell him like I have a weird thing when
a wet rag if it's clean I love the way a
rat wet rag smells okay I'm sorry
because this is because from growing up
doing this right I just a water board
you know so sometimes like we had like
one fan when we were your kid right and
still to this day I have to sleep with
an extra fan like right next to my face
blowing on me right oh that's hella bad
for you dude I'm so immune to it right
through the night every once in a while
like if you were sleeping one of the
brothers would wake up and still it you
would wake up the other brother had on
his bed right you take it back but there
used to be nights because I'm from
Arizona right and it'd be hot as [ __ ]
that I used to get up in the middle of
the night get two racks wet them lay
down put one across my stomach and then
put one across my face with cold water
because I was so hot and I think just
from doing that all the time I got she's
not catch pneumonia I just do that when
I was a kid too actually
yeah you actually just brought up a
memory for myself so I just felt crazy
I did that [ __ ] too and I think just
getting used to that smell like I like
the way they smell good to me for some
reason but like I used to do that when I
was a kid because my parents would never
they wouldn't let me use the fan my hair
like we get mad and they it's like kind
of like Korean fan death whenever every
day I always say yeah they would never
use the AC or the heater and it would
have to get like ridiculous temperatures
or they're like alright let's turn it on
one time that's that's the other
indicator that we started doing better
was my parents started using the AC oh
it was one of the biggest indicators and
the heater they were like we could
afford to use the AC in the heater and
that was probably when I was in high
school I was like 14 or 15 and then we
started using like the amenities like
the Ford like the [ __ ] heaters yeah
that [ __ ] dude I hadn't let me tell you
and this is not even exaggeration I we
never used that [ __ ] to the point where
the first time my parents asked me to
use it I didn't know how to use it
because I didn't know what the [ __ ] it
was I was like how do I turn this on
I've never wasn't allowed to touch that
[ __ ] and we still have the same one is
that old-ass one that that you just kind
of has like the little plastic yeah yeah
it wasn't until my place that I have now
that lived with TIFF where I I realize
like oh the numbers on the thermometer
mistype
it turns on yeah when it's at that
temperature yeah yeah I mean yeah that
way used to be so hot I don't know
honestly I don't remember if we used to
have the a/c on or anything like that
that's not used to be so hot that wet
rag across my body and across my face
would help me fall asleep right and then
especially like with that fan putting
that on me like it would be cold and it
helped me fall asleep but I need to be
cold as hell when I sleep nowadays and I
need to always have a fan cuz like I
don't know like from maybe all the shows
and stuff you know me and my brother
have [ __ ] up ears so like if it gets
too quiet it's loud beep so like I used
some sort of noise or it's like you
smashed on your head oh hey
right you write your bid through so much
[ __ ] now it's like you have to live in
perpetual [ __ ] because house with eleven
people before we leave this podcast room
let me tell you something man this
listen like if I took a photo of where
he live right now and you would you
would this what you guys get somebody
from Tijuana here you know what like I'm
talking about like the ghettoest parts
I've been to looks exactly like where
you live
we got lemons though unless those are
you selling it outside like a little
white girl I should don't like a Loki do
those lemons are flat as [ __ ] today we
got lemons though everybody we got
lemons don't San Gabriel this guy right
here real quick this fools over here
[ __ ] cooking up coronavirus in that
kitchen [ __ ] that [ __ ] is decrepit he
lives in a place right which I don't
even think real time is supposed to be
livable in that situation for real not
like you want to hear a funny story I
don't know if I told you this already
right so yes I live I rent a room out of
a house right and this little Asian lady
and the older Asian guy they run it the
little Asian ladies weird and I finally
got to send you guys a video to see her
right she looks like she's she looks
like she's a ghost
she looks a hundred percent I kid you
not I would be surprised if she was less
than 150 years old yeah she owns your
house she's not a real person she she
she's crazy right but this girl so yeah
number one I remember one time we had to
fix the bathroom upstairs right they had
to get a new toilet so the guy asked me
he was like eh this is the first part do
you have anywhere to stay by chance just
you know just in case they say something
I'm like what do you mean because all of
a sudden they started closing the door
in front of my door and the person right
next to me the door yeah and he's like
well like do you just have somewhere to
stay while they fix the bathroom if the
city comes I was like yeah sure does
that mean
I pay half rent and he was like well why
would you pay our friend I'm like
because you're kicking me out for the
first two weeks of the month yeah like
why would I have to pay for rent and
then like the next day he tells me he's
a a so if the if the city makes us is it
okay if we break down the wall between
you and you're in the next-door neighbor
and put a curtain and I was like nah
I'll move out yeah and there's once well
why not gonna [ __ ] separate my room
with a curtain like number one the wall
is so thin and I was telling them just
like they didn't build it all the way so
there's a crack in the window that I can
literally put my fingers in the other
person's room oh one of the old
neighbors that's the most Asian thing
neighbors that you slim right there
right we used to bless each other on
each other sneezed so I saw almost needs
to back bus you good hero last and then
the [ __ ] guy upstairs had a [ __ ]
little little bird that [ __ ] used to go
crazy all the time I used to be before
ghosts [ __ ] good the bird would just
[ __ ] go berserk out of nowhere right
we asked so that little asian lady lives
there it's totally numb I wake up at
3:00 in the morning too so I run
downstairs the fire alarms are going off
she's like cooking like a [ __ ] full
smorgasbord of food dog there's three
pots and pans on the [ __ ] stove right
and she just cooks random [ __ ]
throughout the day sometimes it smells
mom not gonna lie she makes those little
things I was telling you today
yeah buns whatever [ __ ] yeah sometimes
she makes some stuff that smells [ __ ]
horrendous stinky tofu do it it smells
up the whole house but I love it it's
coffee you know
things like you know I've gotten so used
to it that it's comfortable not best
your whole life though you selling a
battered woman you know I want exactly
you I feel like this is so weird because
he told me how much he pays for the spot
right he pays $700 for this half lit
room this hostel room with bird [ __ ]
it was jacking off and he came onto that
wall it was seat to the other side
that's how it's made out of paper mache
and his [ __ ] landlord is not even
alive it's a ghost have you ever even
touched her I bet you go right through
her and she wears 1 million different
patterns at once yeah she's she's weird
oh you mean do is a spell one question
he goes who's your dad he goes well in
the 17th century I'm not here she's a
ghost from Mulan remember the animated
ones exactly dude that's a the one time
I saved their dog No so real quick you
have way too many stories about the
place that you move I'll tell you this
story real quick so they got a new
little puppy that's 1 million stories of
this they got a new little puppy right a
little border collie black and white
wine actually expensive and so first
time I walk in the house they don't tell
anybody right so I walk in the house I
see the [ __ ] I jump I'm on the stairs so
much there's a [ __ ] skunk in here
right shitty your places is the first
thing that you think about that's how
shitty the stairs instead of leaving hey
but something I look I'm like trying to
see
it'll-it'll calls out the cue sting
right it's all looking at me oh [ __ ] oh
yeah we got a puzzle right so like maybe
three weeks passed by and I come back
into the house and the guy's looking at
me like have you seen happy that's the
dog's name
I was like no I what's up are you sure I
was like yeah no why what's up oh we
can't find him I was like okay oh we
thought you might have maybe you took
him someone said they saw somebody like
they might have saw somebody walking
with a dog I'm like no hide where would
I take the [ __ ] dog here I come back
here like I understand yeah and he's
like well we can't find him I was like
alright well I gotta be at work in like
an hour but I can help you look for him
right I'm gonna go upstairs and the guy
upstairs is like a hey did you he asked
you about the dog they thought that you
stolen yeah ask me he's like yeah they
were like I think Alex took him someone
said they saw someone with a dog so I go
downstairs on my alright where's the
last place you saw this dog and then so
he's like talking I can't see him and I
started to walk up the front door and
he's just happy right and he runs over -
yeah he runs over to this big-ass
bookcase they have on there right and he
starts yelling help help help so I run
over there and I look real quick and all
I see is like the big ass like dresser
laying down and I see like the dog's
feet oh no from there right so I see and
I'm just like [ __ ] I just turned away
and the guy runs downstairs on my - it's
dead dude he's like oh and he's like oh
how he starts going it so I looking like
the feet are moving all my run over
there cuz the guy couldn't lift it up
right and so I can I lift up the thing
and he takes the dog out right and he
said oh man oh man he's like petting it
and [ __ ] I'm like well first let's get
the dog water right like I'll make sure
he's okay and I asked him I'm like how
long has he been missing and then he
goes well it was like six and I heard
like a yeah but the door was open so I
thought like he like cried and he ran
out oh my god yes so this happen at six
it was [ __ ] almost 1 o'clock oh my
god p.m. has been locked here stuck here
6 hours yeah I was ok is the dogs still
alive yeah still alive how dude what the
[ __ ] wait because Superman I know
fact that they have they had a dog for
that long and almost died in there to
their care yeah no so then it was like
oh my God thank you so much right that's
when they like mainly food and all this
type of [ __ ] right there I thought you
stole the [ __ ] dog I was like oh my
gosh man but I love my house i hain't
have hit my house yeah there's no
[ __ ] tour just look up tour Noble and
you'll find this will like I looked up
literally on Craigslist for a house he
pay $700 a month for this woman by the
way I looked up on Craigslist I put a
$700 cap just to see if anything is
affordable for him to get 8,000 postal
rock walls an actual bathroom laundry
it's gonna happen 2020 is the year do
though 2012 do it tomorrow immediately
why could you miss youla angle get no
storage though so like I need a story
though they cool it are they I want to
move out though that is definitely the
plan I have friends that want to move
out and I think that's kind of what I'm
waiting for cuz I don't know if I want
to like my order to get my own spot
right but it's just like I know that how
much money it's going to be and I'll get
another room with an actual wall that's
true that's all that it takes you away
for anybody and it's almost like better
for you to live in a spot without your
friends because that's you don't even
know what's gonna happen and so
sometimes like I almost took it I should
have done it there is another room
upstairs that's a bigger room even has a
ceiling fan and all the type of stuff
that when the even has it even has
lights ooh [ __ ] it's crazy
hey my life for walls my light number
one you have to flip it down to turn it
on right to flip it down hey that [ __ ]
tastes like [ __ ] three minutes for it
to fully be like on bro you you you
gotta move dude
you can stay at a motel 6 by summer at
least alright that's a good that's a
good people one of us won't I don't know
I can't talk want to know why I also
like it so much why the showerhead is
brand new upstairs that [ __ ] is so good
dude dog when you move into a new place
I'll get you a new shower hey don't even
trip that's nice teach you how to make a
showerhead [ __ ] plastic look and
they're like this is a massager and then
you go to a Alex Real Talk
that's every showerhead ever existed
past the 1970s hey I'm telling you right
now most people get a shower with the
hose attached from the outside window
Getti strainer on top my mom has the
best she has one or has a thing from up
top and his hot water
yes I probably and it has like it's like
it shoots down and then she has one
she has three there's one myth our high
level mid down that chute from across
that's like it's so nice when I watched
her house once I was like oh dude I
don't want to leave hey does your mom
know how you live on a regular basis she
do and I did get offer it to live with
her but she lives all the way in upland
which is like that's why it's before way
too far like I have a client in Simi
Valley that would be like an hour and a
half together there's no traffic that's
the only reason why I don't live with
her but summer is a good good you could
move out next week I feel like you can
find something next week
III need a more let me get ready you
know I feel that like my homie Ally she
gonna miss me dog there goes it's not
even alive I'm the only person that
talks to the ghosts oh [ __ ] it
guys jeez brain podcast the most [ __ ]
ridiculous episode we've ever had Alex
might be the most resilient man I've
ever met
maile those do he's dead Alex is David
Goggin live life to the fullest dog look
for the happy thing isn't like you know
you can be sad but if you've tried to
find the happiness in everything you'll
be ok happy you can't even be sad you
can't even see your emotions your lights
turn on after 5 minutes and I'm going to
Seattle tomorrow I'm scared as a
[ __ ] so yeah you good what can
they find you [ __ ] Instagram Alex PA
ggf you can find me a NIC to ear on
Instagram you also listen to the podcast
big man what you could see more these
days that's big mad with like two ways
or 3 years the big mad with 3 G's and
big oh yeah Patrick is on it with us as
well oh I see him I know you guys know
you guys know Pat already be iggg mad
yeah could you guys have made a name
that was that much harder the [ __ ]
find my god you know find the happy
thing you guys catch the genius brain
podcasts on all platforms you know
Spotify iTunes everything else like that
funny stories we just here to get you on
your commute and kind of talk to you
guys throughout your days to keep you
company just keep you entertained
sometimes it's Marsh's sometimes you cry
sometimes you laugh sometimes there's
all the above so we'll see y'all next
time peace peace